-You lost a very closely
contested election,
an election in which there were,
you know, limited access to
polling places,
closed polling places,
polling places closing early.
It seems as though,
and, you know,
I'm not trying to
be unfair to Republicans,
but it seems as though Democrats
want more people to vote
and Republicans
want the opposite.
-Well, Mitch McConnell told us
that he thought more people
being able to vote
was a power grab
because more people
who want power don't have it.
And if we grab it from them,
they're not getting it back.
-So, you have this organization
now, Fair Fight.
Do you feel optimistic that
we're going to move to a place
where more people are,
you know, enfranchised?
-Yeah, so, I think we have to
think about it this way.
Republicans have talked about
voter fraud,
which is largely a myth.
But they've talked about it
for so long, with such energy,
that we take it as a truth.
Those of us of good heart
and good conscience
and true democratic belief,
and I mean small "D" democratic,
we know voter suppression is
real but we never talk about it.
We take it for granted.
My belief is that
by calling it out
and by using
my non-concession speech
and my since actions
to demonstrate
that we can fight back,
that we can actually
reclaim our democracy.
We've been practicing democracy
for a really long time.
America gets it right
most of the time,
but when we stumble,
it is really bad.
And my belief is that we've got
enough of us of good conscience
who will fight
to make it better.
We just have to have someone
willing to talk about it
so we know that
we have a rallying cry
and we have an opportunity.
I got really close.
-You got really close.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got really close
and it was a historic,
even with all the suppression,
it was a historic turnout
for a midterm election.
-Yes.
-And you did not --
when last you were here,
you were talking about you were
not out to flip Trump voters.
You were out to encourage people
who never voted before to vote.
Do you feel like that should be,
as we go into 2020,
do you think that -- do you feel
good about that message?
-Absolutely. Look, my numbers
when I saw you in June,
we wanted to hit -- we wanted
1.5 million people to vote.
We got 1.9 million.
So we really did good.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But what undergirded that is
that we tripled
the number of Latinos.
We tripled the number of
Asian Pacific Islanders.
We increased youth participation
rates by 139%.
1.2 million African-Americans
voted for me.
1.1 million Democrats
voted in 2014.
We know that if you talk to
communities
that are normally ignored
and if you fight for
their right to vote,
you can win elections.
You just can't have someone
acting as the referee,
the umpire, and the scorekeeper
also as your opponent.
-Yes, because your opponent was
the Secretary of State who was,
of course, in charge of voting.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
A little flaw in my process.
Everything else worked like
we thought.
-Absolutely.
Well, I hope
your process will continue.
Of course,
one of the things you did
that I hope the people
in your state will never forget,
you brought Oprah --
-I did.
-And Oprah went
and canvassed voters.
And I'd like to finish --
Oprah Winfrey actually went
and knocked on doors.
-Yes.
-And for people
who are wondering,
how would you react
if that happened to you?
Here's a clip.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
-Hi, Denise.
-Hi, Oprah.
-I think -- I mean,
I hope you got her vote.
-Oh, God, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-No, no, no, because they'll
accuse me of voter fraud.
She lives in Illinois.
-Yeah.
-But she really helped --
Oh, you mean the young woman.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Yes.
-Okay, got it.
Oprah would never.
Because she is not registered
in Georgia.
-Exactly.
-Thank you.
There we are.
Because fair is fair, right?
Fair is fair.
-In fact, we won a fair fight.
-Yeah. There you go.
-Dot com.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It is always such a pleasure
to see you.